today is one of the busiest days for
Christmas returns so let's have some fun
and play a bad gifts return edition of
Supermarket Showdown
I love that music
that's right we're gonna guess the cause
to some of the worst holiday gifts
whoever guesses without going over wins
and we're using Walmart prices and by
the way I don't know any of the answers
in advance only the judge does I do not
uh you were trying to get some answers
yeah but I didn't let's rattle the
competition you would have all right
let's do number one this is a fruitcake
did not know that they actually still
sold these things one fruit okay we want
to hold that fruit kick up now is that
what
okay take a picture of this okay where
are you is that one or is that one
does that appear in nature yeah
I've never eaten a few fruitcakes it
never will two fruitcakes if you send
somebody that you can get charged with a
hate crime
you can return a fruitcake
if they're this hard you can oh man all
right so what's the price of The
Fruitcake everybody at their answers one
fruit kick I don't know two of them in
one pack all right Dana's gonna win I
can feel it I can't I can't Uncorked
this I'm here take mine thank you very
much
I'm going 1280 what are you American
Dana eight Geraldo try to keep up I'd
say yeah
that's a low ball 950. what is the
answer
11 48 do I win oh you win the league
and then return it stop the stuff all
right good job
uh Three Kings Day I will be celebrating
that yeah all right here's some apparel
if you can call socks apparel we have a
bag of white athletic socks who knows
they're for men white athletic socks
wide Comfort brand with a reinforced toe
and ventilation channels oh fancy they
really make a bland pair of socks sounds
so happening
they're from Dickies so you know they're
good all right everybody socks what's
the price I say 12 bucks
going with 99 you're really Playing for
Keeps 15 American okay and the answer is
what
10 98. oh
[Music]
yeah
yeah but I was in this field
I got robbed all right Dana has one
Heraldo has one let's continue with some
home decor God I can't live laugh love
sign do we have that here live can I see
laugh
with a rope dangling from it let's see
how much they're gonna upsell that uh
that's true you know what price is up
I'm going 24. we're going 20. I'm going
high because they usually sell these
also at places where they take advantage
and sell you fudge and weird stuff
[Laughter]
11.69 116.
Geraldo again is that right you are of
the people yeah
zero I own all to my coaches in college
kitchen appliances what this is an
electric can opener and it's from Amazon
it's quite heavy who has room for that
electric can opener who opens cans yeah
do people still do that they got
preservatives if you open a can yeah not
a good thing not a good thing I like
beans in a can you do oh why buy buy
and soak them and boil them okay
electric can opener and this looks
pretty nice I'm gonna go
twenty one dollars
and I bet this is an electron this is
from China Dana this they have so this
is why it's not 21
25 what's the answer
24.95 he went over oh you win
wow I guess I don't shop I got it in
five cents struggling I am back in the
game don't sleep on the Community
College I think the inflation has
affected these prices you guys need to
win this one to face off against Geraldo
for the tiebreaker the final one is more
athletic gear a set of hand weights
would you mind giving us a pump this is
what they got to do to make me work out
in this building they've tried every way
they can to tackfully tell me to work
out just lift the weights it's a gig
don't strain yourself what are those
five pounds yeah
five pounds what are the weights it's
2.2 kilos thank you
[Music]
just so you can read it that's a 25.
that's a 20 yeah I'm sorry I wrote 18.
did you have trouble erasing I think I
dropped the Eraser you have an eraser
geraldo's face
18.
judge
21.99.
wow
do I win the weights yes you know what
they want me to have he needs them
I need to get myself together after I
take this off okay you look together all
right everybody ah that was tough for
Waters hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else